des centaines de migrants arrivés au
québec par le chemin rock simple comme
cette femme sont présentement préposés
aux bénéficiaires dans les ch et celle
des et résidences pour personnes âgées
du québec chez nos conclusions on voit
nos parrains qui sont entrés de
préemption et de leurs parents c'est
comme une responsabilité qu'on a
pandémie ou pas dix-sept autres
demandeuses d'asile elle se doit d'aider
les aînés
on peut pas laisser les personnes âgées
seules comme ça là dont on fait appel à
nos coeurs
une patiente infectées ne comprenait pas
pourquoi la préposée se mettait en
danger
je vous aime c'est parce que c'est pour
ça que je suis là
elle était très complet ça fait du bien
que je pouvais faire sourire quelques
elle a fini par contracté le virus
et je veux aussi reconnaître le travail
incroyable ottawa et québec ont maintes
fois c'est lui le travail de tous les
travailleurs essentiels qui ne comptent
plus leurs heures et qui se sont exposés
au virus
parfois sans l'équipement de protection
adéquats la directrice du centre na rive
et a joint sa voix à celle d'autres
organismes de la communauté haïtienne de
montréal pour qu'ottawa offre plus que
sa gratitude à ces migrants aux
premières lignes de la lutte contre la
copie 19 la meilleure façon pour le
québec de leur dire merci
c'était vraiment de que le gouvernement
fédéral créé un programme spécial
permettant la régularisation du statut
mais d'aller travailler pour aider l'est
qui sont vulnérables
mais ça va faire du bien si au moins on
sait que on le pratique ce que nous
sommes en train de faire interrogé à ce
sujet le 8 mai dernier
voici ce qu'a répondu la vice première
ministre du canada le canada a un
système un système juste à une système
très bien réglée pour décider qui a le
droit d'asile au canada et c'est
important pour nous d'être un pays des
doigts a et on continuera d'être ça
ninette piou ne peut imaginer qu ottawa
puisque les expulser du pays
non ce serait inacceptable non non non
sterlé lucien serait anéantie par un
refus du fédéral
elle qui est atteinte de lakovic 19 ce
serait un signe de gratitude parce qu'on
l'a fait beaucoup on leur a donné le
mieux de nous mêmes malgré tout malgré
la maladie il est là pour eux mais je
pense aussi mais les autres aussi ils
savent que au large de aussi les
demandeurs d'asile attendent une réponse
d'ottawa ici valérie michaela bayne
radio-canada moret